we want to share some urgent warnings
about a potential security issue on the
internet that could affect hundreds of
millions of people it involves a piece
of code called log 4j used by companies
you interact with like amazon apple
twitter and even the popular video game
minecraft sean henry is president of
services and chief security officer at
crowdstrike a top cyber security firm
he's a former fbi executive assistant
director good morning to you we
appreciate you being here help me
understand i am a luddite what does all
of this mean and why is it a problem
so log4j is a very common and widely
used utility uh open source library the
software developers use to monitor and
track what's happening on their
application so essentially it's kind of
foundational in a lot of applications
it's it's quite ubiquitous there are
millions of servers around the globe
that utilize it a couple of weeks ago
there was a vulnerability that was
reported in log4j in the code and
hackers are able to exploit that and
once the hackers exploit it they
essentially have an open door into the
network
and because this is used so frequently
around the world once hackers get a
foothold into the enterprise they really
have a open open day within the
environment they've got access to data
they can exfiltrate data so it's really
quite significant and a major concern
for companies around the globe
sean what's the biggest concern and what
data people could steal and how do you
protect yourself how do we counter this
so it's really any type of data customer
records intellectual property corporate
strategies etc we're talking about
corporations now but adversaries once
they have access they also can do things
like deploy ransomware uh once they've
got that open door it's really this uh
the sky's the limit they've got access
to anything in that environment we see
adversaries uh leveraging these these
opportunities we see nation states that
are targeting corporations and
government agencies looking for ways in
uh so that they can utilize their skills
to get to the most important data that
they can either use from a financial
perspective or from a national security
perspective
now sean you mentioned government
agencies you know we appreciate you
telling us what we can do but oftentimes
i think about who's above us and how
they can help so what is the government
doing to help with this threat
yeah the government is fully engaged in
this sysa is the federal government
agency as part of dhs
that oversees and looks for
vulnerabilities they work very
cooperatively with the fbi and with nsa
we're working with cisa as our other
companies through a joint cyber defense
collaborative sharing intelligence with
them letting them know what we're seeing
in organizations environments so that
they can help to develop the protocols
to overcome this vulnerability need
you know i know there's been supply
chain issues when it comes to
electronics and how does that play into
the cyber attack situation
yeah the supply chain is something we're
very very concerned about as we look
forward into 2022 essentially anybody
that you do business with
vendors contractors subcontractors that
might be targeted uh are a potential
ingress into your environment so we see
adversaries targeting companies and
using that as a leverage to get access
into other companies they might not have
access to we also see adversaries
targeting software so that they can by
expo or getting infiltrating companies
exploiting data when people and
companies download and update their
software in some cases they're actually
downloading these back doors into their
environment so the adversaries have
become incredibly creative they're very
very sophisticated they're spending a
lot of time money and effort to gain
access to these networks because of the
incredible
data that they've got the value of that
information is so important to them
sean uh like many of our viewers you
know i have kids at home i have 17 15
and 11 and they use every social media
platform they are in the digital space
purchasing things all of the time and
i'm usually a little bit hesitant to
give them my credit card or allow them
to do things so what should i be telling
my kids and what can the viewer be
telling their family members that are
using the internet like we all are
yeah in these cases that we're talking
about with log4j these are really issues
that need to be addressed by the
corporations that are building the
applications but as a user
as a consumer it's really important to
understand uh not to click on emails
on
links within emails or open attachments
in emails from somebody that's untrusted
people are getting ads and unusual uh
emails from folks that sometimes contain
malware you've got to be alert
unusual changes in your credit card um
you know the consumer needs to be aware
that adversaries are are targeting them
on a regular basis because of the value
of the type of information that they've
got access to nate
sean henry this information is so
valuable thank you so much for joining
us